السلام عليكم واهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه من
ما وراء الخبر مشهد اخر تكرر اليوم من
مشاهد التدهور الامني في ليبيا 16 جنديا
قتلوا في هجوم على حاجز للجيش في منطقه ام
الرشراش الواقعه بين مدينتي ترهونه وبني
وليد جنوب العاصمه طرابلس
قفوا مع حد التطور الجديد لنناقشه من
زاويتين ما هي اسباب وهشاشه الوضع الامني
رغم المبادرات والمحاولات الرسميه
المتكرره لتحصيله
يمكن ان يرسم التوصل الى رؤيه واضحه
للعداله الانتقاليه تحتوي الجميع في تهدئه
الاوضاع وتهيئه اجواء الاستقرار
اذا فقد قتل 16 جنديا ليبيا اصيب اربعه
بجروح في هجوم مسلحه على حاجز بمنطقه
الرشراش بين مدينتي ترهون وبني وليد هذا
الاعتداء ضمن سلسله اعتداءات وتفجيرات
واغتيالات استهدفت مراكز امنيه ومباني
حكوميه
هو الاصعب بالنسبه للحكومه في ظل فوضى
السلاح والميليشيات
بعد الثوره والاستقرار الامني المعادله
الصعبه حجزوا الرشراش بين مدينه تيتر هنا
وبني وليد جنوب طرابلس كان مسرحا لاحدث
اعتداء على الجيش الليبي قتل في الهجوم
الذي شنه مسلح من 16 جنديا كم الجيش استلم
الحاجز من كتائب الثوار قبل ايام والمنطقه
كانت دائما توصف بالمتوتره لطالما اعتبرت
مدينه بني وليد معقلا للعقيدي معمر
القذافي الذي اطاحت الثوره بحكمه هجوم
الرشراش وجزء من سلسله احداث عنف تستمر
منذ شهور وتجعل احلال الامن مساله بالغه
الصعوبه على اي حكومه في السلطه حكومه
وجدت نفسها اكثر من مره في حرج بسبب
الاعتداءات على السفاره الاجنبيه اخرها
محاوله اقتحام السفاره الروسيه في طرابلس
يوم الخميس الماضي ما دفع موسكو الى اجلاء
موظفيها وعائلاتهم من ليبيا مهما كانت
اسباب محاوله الاقتح فالبلد يفتقر الى
جهاز امني يفرض سيطرته على المؤسسات
الحكوميه والافراد سلطه الميليشيات
المسلحه وما اكثرها تبدو احيانا اقوى من
سلطه الدوله الفتيه قائمه الهجمات
والتفجيرات طويله استهدف مبنى تابع لوزاره
الخارجيه في مدينه بنغازي بسياره ملغمه في
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر الماضي في يوليو
الماضي وفي نفس المدينه فشرت محكمه شملت
الاغتيالات الناشطه الحقوقي عبد السلام
المسماري والعقيد عبد الله رفيده رئيس
غرفه الشرطه في مصراته لماذا كل هذا الدم
والدمار اهو السلاح الذي انتشر خلال
الثوره ام النعره القبليه التي كانت
مكبوته لعقود وانفجرت بعد سقوط حكم
الكذافي وما دور قله الخبره السياسيه لدى
المسؤولين الجدد وتعطش تيارات تسيطر على
ميليشيات للسلطه مهما كان الثمن التجربه
الديمقراطيه في ليبيا تعيش مرحله صعبه
وحده وطن وسلامه كل شبر وانسان فيه بل
وحتى استقرار دول الجوار في خطر
موضوع ليله نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من طرابلس
علي شيخي الناطق باسم رئاسه الاركان
الليبيه ومحمد سعد معذب عضو المؤتمر
الوطني الليبيه العام من بنغازي مع الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي الدكتور صالح السنوسي
نبدا مع السيد علي الشيخ الناطق باسم
رئاسه الاركان الليبيه من طرابلس ونسال
يعني السيد علي شيخي للاسف ليس الحادث
الاول لكنه حتما الاخطر الذي تعيشه ليبيا
هذه الايام السؤال ما الذي يبرر استمرار
وتكرار مثل هذه الحوادث
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا هذا الحادث
المؤسف الذي
المؤسف الذي حدث اليوم وصباح اليوم
يعتبر هو
يشمل اكبر الضحايا في في صفوف الجيش في
هذه الايام
جاء طبعا هذه الحوادث مستمره هي ونحن في
الاسبوع الماضي فقدنا عدد كبير من زملائنا
الضباط من في مدينه بنغازي واليوم ايضا
قتل فرد من افراد القوات الصاعقه في
بنغازي وهذه يعني احداث متكرره ونحاول
تفاديها ولكن يبدو ان انتشار السلاح وتعدد
العصابات المسلحه التي تهدف الى زياده
زعزعه الامن وبث الفتنه في ليبيا تمكنت
اليوم من هذا من ان تضرب هذا الموقع الذي
يخص الجيش الليبي وكل الذين استشهدوا في
هذا الحادث وجرحوهم اعضاء في الجيش
رسميين يعني عسكريين رسمي ين وليسوا ثوار
او اي جهه اخرى مسلحه
مثل هذه الهجومات يطفوا الى السطح موضوع
فوضى السلاح والمليشيات سمعنا في كل مره
ايضا احاديث عن مبادرات
ومحاولات ربما لجمع هذا السلاح ودمج هذه
الميليشيات لماذا باءت جميعها بالفشل
نحن الذين نتحدث عن دمجهم دائما هم الثوار
المسلحون وهؤلاء يعني نحن لا نوجه التهم
اليهم بقدم من وجه هذه التهم الى العصابات
الاخرى التي هي لا تريد الاستقرار ليبيا
بسبب انها مدائنه واذا استقرت الدوله
سيقدمون الى المحاكمات هؤلاء هم الذين
يثيرون هذه الفتن ويقومون بمثل هذه
العمليات وعمليه الدمج هي ما زالت مستمره
ومزاله تبدا الجهود كبيره في هذا الاتجاه
وقد تحققت بعض التقدم في هذا الاتجاه ولعل
دمج هذه هو الذي زاد من وتيره الاعتداء
على العسكريين لمنع الثوار من الاندماج في
في القوات المسلحه
نتحول السيد محمد سعد معزه بعض المؤتمر
الوطني الليبي العام من طرابلس ايضا يعني
الى جانب هذا الوضع الامني المتردي سيد
معذب اين السياسي في هذا ايضا
اي دور تلعبه السياسه ايضا في عدم استتباب
الامن
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اشكركم على
استضافتي هو طبعا بالنسبه للسياسي هو
يتمثل في السلطتين السلطه التشريعيه
السياديه وهي المؤتمر الوطني العام
والسلطه التنفيذيه اللي هي الحكومه انا
ارى من جانب السلطه السياديه التشريعيه
ادت دورها في هذا المجال يعني
تم اصدار القوانين اللازمه وموجوده اصلا
عدد كبير من القوانين نحن لا نحتاج الى
قوانين يعني تجرم مثل هذه الجرائم وهذه
الانتهاكات من قتل واختصاب وسلب اموال
واحتداء على المؤسسات الدوله واعتداء على
مصادر الدخل الليبيه وايضا المؤتمر رصد
هذا العام 9 مليار دينار لوزرتي الداخليه
والدفاع فالامكانيات الماديه موجوده
القوانين الموجوده الذي يغيب على المشهد
في هذا الموضوع للاسف الشديد هو الاراده
السياسيه الاراده السياسيه لم تكن موجوده
في هذا الامر يعني هناك حجج عند الذين
المفترض فيه من يتخذوا قرارات رادعه
وحازمه للحاسمه
لماذا تغيب الاراده السياسيه ان كانت جميع
الظروف والامكانيات مهيئه
هم هم يتعللون بالحكمه والتروي واخذ
الامور بالسلم والمهادنه ولكن للاسف
الشديد هذه السياسه اثبتت فشلها يعني
الدوله اذا اريد بناءها لابد من الحزم ولا
بد من الحزم
وانا ارى ان كل معظم فئات الشعب الليبي في
هذا الجانب وهي تطالب الحكومه وتطالب
المؤتمر بان يكون الموقف حازم وحاسم ويكفي
مهادنا ويكفي سكوت عن هذه الانتهاكات
ويكفي صوت الحكمه صوت الحكمه لا ينفع في
هذه الامور يعني وهذا راي يعبر
الاجراءات التي ترتؤون بانه يجدر فعليا
القيام بها الخطوات التي يمكن ان تؤتي
اكولها وبالتالي يخف مستوى العنف الذي نرى
في ليبيا اليوم
الاجراءات هي هي الكره الان في ملعب الناس
اللي هم ماسكين اللي هم مسؤولين على الامن
المفترض ان تتخذ اجراءات رادعه وحازمه
وحاسمه ضد كل من ينتهك كل القوانين
القوانين اللي هي موجوده يعني هم لا
يحتاجون للتشريعات وهم لا يحتاجون الى الى
تمويل مادي هذا كله متوفر لديهم
تشريعات موجوده الامكانيات الماديه موجوده
دعنا نتحول لبن غازي وضيفنا من هناك
الكاتب المحلي السياسي دكتور صالح سنوسي
دكتور صالح اين وجه الخلل اذا ان كانت
التشريعات موجوده ان كانت الامكانيات
الماديه موجوده ما الذي يحول دون وضع
مستقر ينشده الليبي
نعم هي التشريعات موجوده
والامكانيات موجوده ولكن في حقيقه الامر
هناك مفارقه في المشهد السياسي الليبي وهو
ان السلطه التي تمتلك الشرعيه لا تمتلك
القوه
والقوه تمتلكها اطراف اخرى ليست شرعيه
ليست منتخبه ولا تظهر على المسرح السياسي
باعتبارها تمثل يعني مختلف المجتمع الليبي
هناك قوه مبعثره بين مجموعه من القوى
الداخليه الاقليم سواء في يد الكتائب
والميليشيات وهي التي تمتلك السلاح وتمتلك
القوه بينما السلطه التشريعيه او الحكومه
هي لا شك تتمتع ناحيه النظريه بكونها سلطه
شرعيه ومنتخبه ولكنها في الحقيقه لا تملك
القوه اذا الاشكاليه هنا الاشكاليه في ان
ينبغي اولا
جمع هذه القوى الفاعله على الارض
ومحاوله اجراء
ما نسميه يعني لقاء بين هذه القوه التي
تمتلك التي تمتلك القوه تحت مظله السلطه
التي تمتلك الشرعيه من اجل على الاقل ما
الذي حال دون ذلك لحد الان دكتور صالح ما
الذي حال دون التوصل الى ذلك لحد الان
خاصه انا سمعنا عن مبادرات كثيره في هذا
الاتجاه
هو في الحقيقه الان تجري هذه المبادره
وهناك مبادرات كثيره تدعو الى مؤتمر عام
تلتقي فيه جميع القوى الفاعله في ليبيا من
اجل ان تتوصل مثل ما قلت الى حد ادنى يتفق
عليه الجميع من اجل ان يخرجوا من عمق
الزجاجه من هذه ان يحققوا شيئين فقط الامن
والاستقرار لان بدون امن واستقرار لن تكون
هناك دوله وبدون امن واستقرار لن يكون
هناك ازدهار ممكن ان يكون هناك امن
واستقرار ولا يكون ازدهار لكن لن يكون
هناك ازدهار الا بوجود امن واستقرار ويبدو
لي هذا في الغالب من مصلحه كل القوى التي
تريد بناء الدوله يبقى في هذه الحاله بعض
القوه التي قد تشد عن هذا اللقاء وبالتالي
تبقى معزوله وتعرف وبالتالي نكف عن تبادل
الاتهامات
ان هناك اطراف هي التي قامت بهذا الفعل
هناك اطراف قامت في هذا الهجوم هناك بقايا
من النظام السابق هناك المتطرفون هناك
عصابات الجريمه لا الان عندما يحصل هذا
اللقاء وتفرز جميع القوى بحيث تظهر القوه
التي لا تريد ان تلتقي على اي
مشروع وطني كحد ادنى دون وضح ذلك
نعم الدكتور صالح واضح ذلك طبعا سنعود
اليك دعنا فقط مجمل النقاط التي طرحتها
نحولها السيد علي شيخي ضيفنا من طرابلس
يعني كثيرا لما سمعنا هذه النغمه عدم قدره
الاجهزه الامنيه والجيش على فرض سيطرته
والسؤال ربما ما الذي يحول دون بناء جهاز
امني فعلي قادر على بناء سيطرته على
المؤسسات الحكوميه وعلى الافراد وعلى هذه
الميليشيات التي نسمع كثيرا عنها
الدكتور اجاب على هذا السؤال هو ان طبعا
مقدره الجيش الليبي او القوى الامنيه غير
قادره منذ التحرير من اكتوبر عام 2011 كان
الجيش منتهي بعد التحرير واصبحت هناك قوه
اخرى هي قوه الثوار الذين يعني ساهموا
بالسلاح في انهاء النظام السابق وهذه
القوه لم تنضم الى الجيش كلها واصبحت هي
القوه التي تمثل القوه الحقيقيه على الارض
واثناء بناء الجيش حدث تحالف السابق بين
القوه والجيش واصبحت تحت سيطره الجيش الى
حد ما الا ان في احداث حدثت والسلطه
التشريعيه اصدرت قرارات بحل الدروع التي
كانت هي جزء من الجيش بعد احداث بنغازي في
شهر يونيو الماضي هذا لعله اثر واغرى
الجهات الاخرى والعصابات الاخرى في زعزعه
الامن
الكلام الذي قاله الدكتور هو عين الصواب
واراه هو هو
المخرج ليبيا عن كل من يملكون القوه يجب
ان يتحاوروا ويجب ان يكونوا هناك حوار
بينهم وتستغل هذه القوه في حمايه البلاد
جميعا الى ان يتم بناء المؤسسات الدوله
الامنيه والعسكريه وتستطيع ان تقوم هذه
بواجباتها السيد معذب قبل طبعا ان نخوض في
مساله
الحلول وما يجدر فعله دعنا نفكك تقريبا ما
يحدث لماذا الى حد الان مع تكرار مثل هذه
الحوادث على اختلاف مستوياتها سواء ضد
منشاه حكوميه ضد افراد من الجيش او حتى
افراد من ربما حقوقيين سمعنا عن ذلك اشخاص
يعملون في الحكومه ايضا ضد سفارات ايضا لم
نسمع كثيرا لا اعتقال لا عن اعتقالات ولا
عن محاكمات ولا عدت حتى عن نتائج هذه
التحقيقات ما الذي يحول دون ذلك اين
الاسباب التي تكمن وراء هذا فعليا
هو السبب هو سبب واحد كما ذكرت انا هذا في
هذا في رايي وهذا في اعتقادي انه غياب
الاراده السياسيه مش غياب امكانيات مش
غياب قدرات وبعدين هذه المساله ليست انا
بالنسبه لي انا لا ارى ان الجيش له علاقه
بهذا الموضوع الاصل فيها امن داخلي قوى
الامن الداخلي وزاره الداخليه بالذات هي
المسؤوله عن هذا الامر ولكن الامر يعني
وين ما تبحث عن اي حادثه تقع اي انتهاك
يحدث في داخل سواء في داخل المدن او
خارجها نجد ان الاجراءات التي اتخذت
الرادعه اللي اتخذت حيال هذا الامر
اجراءات عديمه الجدوى عديمه
التي تراها انت عديمه الجذونات عن الخطوات
التي قامت فعليا بها السلطات الليبيه
حينما يحدث اي اي انتهاك امني الاصل في
الجهات الامنيه المسؤوله عن حفظ الامن ان
تتعقب الجولات وخاصه ان حوادث كثيره مثلا
في بنغازي تقع حوادث كثيره وللاسف الشديد
معروفين من يقوم بهذه الحوادث معروفه
عناوين معروفه اسمائهم ولكن لا يتم القبض
عليهم لا ادري لماذا يعني هذا يعني التعلل
دائما التعلم موجود نحن لا نريد ان نوجد
مصادمات نحن نريد ان نعالج الامر بالحكمه
هذه الامور وهذه الاختراقات هذا انهيار
دوله دوله الليبيه الان تتجه الى الانهيار
بهذا الشكل يعني مواني مقفوله الان اكثر
من شهرين نفط موقوف عن التصدير ثلاث ارباع
النفط لا يخرج من من اماكن التصدير
اماكن طرق تقفل قتل خطف وهكذا يعني الامور
تعالج بطريقه اي حكمه في هذا الامر لا لا
ارى ان الحكمه هي ان تستخدم القوه والعنف
لحل هذه المشكله اشرت الى نقطه كررتها
لثاني مره غياب الاراده السياسيه دعني
اتحول بها للدكتور صالح السنوسي في بنغازي
الى اي مدى تشاطر وجهه النظر هذه غياب
الاراده السياسيه هناك من يعز ما يحدث
الان الى قله الخبره السياسيه لدى
المسؤولين الليبيين الجدد كيف ترى انت
الاسباب الحقيقيه الكامنه وراء هذا الوضع
هو الحقيقه لا شك ان هناك غياب خبره كما
راينا من خلال مثلا مسيره المؤسسه
السياسيه التي انتخبناها وهي السلطه
التشريعيه والحكومه هناك غياب خبره في
معالجه مجموعه من الاحداث والتصرفات
والمواقف هذا لا شك بذلك ولكن
مثل ما قلت ان
الغياب
مثل ما قال الاستاذ عضو المؤتمر يعني لا
توجد
نيه سياسيه او لا
بمعنى لا توجد يعني
ايرادة سياسيه من قبل السلطه لحسم هذا
الامر هو هذه الاراده احيانا يعوقها عدم
قدرتها على الفعل وايضا يعوقها وجود بعض
التباينات بين مكونات المؤتمر الوطني هناك
ايضا نوع من يبدوني الصراع بين يعني الكتل
الم في المؤتمر الوطني مما قد يعاقل بعض
القرارات التي يحزن فيها المؤتمر يعني
امره وبالتالي يعني
يحول هذا الى فعل فالاراده السياسيه
احيانا يشلها عدم وجود اتفاق بين القوى
التي تشكل
الفعل السياسي
دكتور طبعا سنعود النظر سنعود لجنه الوقت
نعم نرجو ان تبقى معنا طبعا سنعود لمواصله
تداعيات هذا الموضوع وربما بعض ما يراه
البعض مخارج
لهذا الوضع الامني المستعصي في ليبيا كل
ذلك سنناقش مع ضيوفنا الكرام من بنغازي
وطرابلس بعد فاصل قصير معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش الملف الامني في ليبيا
في ضوء الهجوم الذي وقع اليوم على طريقه
ترهون بني وليد واستهدف نقطه عسكريه وقتل
فيه سته عشر شخصا مباشره الى طرابلس
والسيد علي شيخ الناطق باسم رئاسه الاركان
الليبيه في ظل هذا الوضع السيد علي شيخي
ماذا عن الخطط الامنيه التي رصدت ووضعت
بمعنى هل بات الامر ضروريا الان فعليا
واكثر من اي وقت مضى لاعاده هيكله اجهزه
الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه
لمنحها ربما الامكانيات اللازمه في مواجهه
هذا الوضع وهل تفكرون في استعانه ربما
باطراف خارجيه لهذا الغرض
نحن نعمل على اساس اعاده هيكله الجيش
وتقويه الجيش
وادخال عناصر جديده لتقويه الجيش وايضا
عمليه الادماج وضعت لها خطه الان بدات في
العمل وسيتم ادماج مجموعه كبيره ان شاء
الله من الثوار على دفعات في الجيش ولكن
عمليه الاستعانه باعتراف اجنبيه هي اولا
اراده سياسيه وقرار سياسي يعود الى
السلطات السياسيه سواء في الحكومه وفي
المؤتمر والجيش لا علاقه له بهذا الموضوع
الجيش اذا لا علاقه له بهذا الموضوع نعود
الى طبعا موضوع ربما الاراده السياسيه
التي اشرت اليها سيد معذب وهي اكثر نقطه
ربما طرحت في هذه المرحله ما الذي ينقص
الان الطبقه السياسيه الموجوده في ليبيا
خاصه وانها انتخبت من الشعب الليبي حتى
تتحرك فيها هذه الاراده السياسيه لبس
الامن في نهايه الامر في ليبيا ما السبيل
الى ذلك
هو الامر يعني لما نقول اراده سياسيه
الامر لا يحتاج يعني بالنسبه للمؤتمر انا
اتحدث كعضو في مؤتمر المؤتمر ادى واجبه من
هذه اللحيه كما قلت في بدايه الحديث
التشريعات موجوده والاموال ارصدت هذه هي
مهمه المؤتمر في هذه الناحيه
التنفيذيه لاجهزه التنفيذيه نعم التنفيذ
هذه اشياء عمليه على ارض الواقع هذه لا
تحتاج الى الى مؤتمر ولا تحتاج
بالضبط
تتكون من نقاط واحد اثنان ثلاثه
نعم يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال يعني ما
الذي يمنع وزاره الداخليه بان تنشي قوه
تدخل سريع مدربه تدريب عالي جدا
ومجهزه باحدث الاجهزه هذه القوه تتدخل في
اللحظه المناسبه لما تصير هي الانتهاكات
لا تحدث بشكل يومي ولا تحدث في مكان واحد
تحدث في اماكن متفرقه وفي امكاننا نستفيد
من خبرات وتجارب العالم الاخر بدون ما
نستحضر اشخاص ولا كذا ممكن استحضار خبراء
مثلا اجهزه معدات تجارب دول اخرى نستطيع
في هذا المجال وخاصه الاموال رسلت يعني
الاموال اللي رسلت هذا العام تسعه مليار
ما بين وزاره الداخليه وزاره الدفاع يعني
ماذا ينتظرون
يعني عمليه مازال الاسطوانه الاولى بناء
الجيش ومش عارف شنو هو ادم الثوار وما
زالت نفس الاسطوانه تتكرر من بدايه العام
ونحن على مشارف نهايه العام ولم تتحقق هذه
هذه هذه
المقوله التي السؤال
الان وهو سؤال الاخير لضيق وقتنا تقريبا
انتهاء الدكتور صالح السنوسي ضروره وضع
رؤيه لفكره العداله الانتقاليه بما يسمح
باستيعاب الجميع في نهايه الامر ويحقق في
نهايه الامر هذا الاستقرار المنشود
الاراده
القانون العداله الانتقاليه هو جزء من
الامن والاستقرار او خطه الامن المستقرار
في ليبيا وكما قلت ورده ان لا يمكن نجاح
اي قانون او اي مبادره ما لم يجري اتفاق
بين القوى الفاعله وهذا ما ردده الاخ عضو
المؤتمر قال نحن عملنا كل شيء وماذا
يمنعهم من التنفيذ التنفيذ لان هناك قوه
على الارض تمنع تنفيذ هذه البرامج
والمخططات وهذه القوه هي التي ينبغي جمعها
ووضعها في مواجهه
حقائق لكي تتخذ موقف واضح وطني او تخرج عن
اجماع القوى الوطنيه لان على الارض توجد
قوه اخرى هل قرارات والقوانين التي سواء
تخول الحكومه ان تقوم بك ذا وكذا او قانون
المصالحه الوطنيه والعداله وكل هذا يحتاج
الى قوه رعاه والقوه من هي هذه القوه ما
المقصود تحديدا لجنه حكماء لجنه حكماء
مثلا تجمع الجميع ربما مؤتمر للمصالحه
والمصالحه والمكاشفه سميه ما شئت ينبغي
الجميع تحت
نعم هذا كان دائما تصوري منذ امد بعيد انه
ينبغي ان تقوم بهذه المبادره مجموعه من
الحكماء والشخصيات واصحاب المكان
الاجتماعي والثقافيه يجب ان تختار مجموعه
لكي تقوم بهذه المبادره وتجمع حريق ولان
هذه القوه معروفه على الاقل كل ما يجري من
اعمال
وعنف
وخروقات كلها خلفها نخب نخب هي التي تقود
هذه الافعال وهذه النخب معروفه انا عندما
اقول نخبه ليس بالضروره انه يعني
تعبير ايجابي قد يكون سلبي بمعنى العناصر
القادره على تحريك المشهد السياسي
والعسكري في ليبيا والاجتماع هذه النخفيه
التي يجب استهدافها وجمع من خلال هذه
اللجنه على تتكون من كل ذوي المكانه
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه ايضا ثقافيه في
ليبيا لكي يعني تصل الى جمع هؤلاء هو
وضعهم امامك واجبهم الوطني ومن يتخلص يكون
معروف والجميع يقع شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور
صالح سنوسي الكاتب المحلل السياسي كما
نشكر جزيل الشكر السيد محمد سعد معذب
الوطني الليبي العام ونشكر جزيل الشكر
ضيفنا علي شيخي الناطق باسم رئاسه الاركان
الليبيه وكلاهما كان معنا من طرابلس لهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه السلام عليكم